Speaker 1: I want to do a short segment on Don
Jr and Maria BARTIROMO. Maria BARTIROMO has
become one of the biggest Trump family, brown
posers really in the world, but in particular
on Fox News. And she had a wild interview and
I'm not making any speculative claims about
Don Jr's possible opera use. I'm just not going
to do that on this show. I'm just going when I say
he seems sped up, I just mean it seems like the
videos of him talking are sped up and donald trump
jr has now co-founded something called Maxim News.
I have no idea what it is. It's very uninteresting
to me, but it's like they've got rumble,
they've got truth, social, now it's MSM news
who can even keep track of all these different
things. And he showed up and he is talking
about panic, about free speech and different
things. These interviews just go nowhere.
Speaker 2: I think that the
Conservatives for a decade now,
like these people are living in a bubble. They're
not looking for a level playing field, Maria.
They're looking for an advantage. They were always
thrilled when they have that advantage, as though
they don't have enough advantages already.
All right. They control the mainstream media,
$1,000,000,000,000 enterprise they have basically.
Speaker 1: I love when they go on Fox and slam
the mainstream media as if Fox News isn't
part of the same corporate media apparatus
that they criticize all.
Speaker 2: Of big tech,
another trillion dollar enterprise. They had
all of social media again until you came up
with true social. And then Elon Musk said, hey,
how about some free speech on Twitter as well?
Oh, my God, you know, the outrage and the panic
and you see it. And that's why you see the leak
about the Supreme Court. They need something
and they have nothing to motivate their people.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, aiding creep, we still
don't know who did the Supreme Court leak, but
it's increasingly looking like the best hypotheses
are that it was a right winger who did the leak.
But that's just not going. Convenient for them.
Speaker 2: American people are awake to it.
They're starting to see what's real.
Speaker 1: Wow. They're awake.
It almost sounds like they're woke.
Speaker 2: Oh, what happened to the algorithms?
The second the musk thing was announced, they saw
the engagement that they're getting on social,
and they realized that they've been in
a rigged game for very long. They see
it and you can no longer hide it. Maria.
Speaker 1: And now the crazy thing about
this appearance, other than the
fact that everything that he says
doesn't make any sense, is he was so
hopped up on, let's call it energy that
he ranted for several minutes to the point
where Maria BARTIROMO tried to interrupt
him and was isn't even able to.
Speaker 2: Russian disinformation
until it wasn't. Once they got what they wanted,
the truth no longer mattered. So now they can
say it's true. They see the disaster that goes.
Biden's administration is so now they're saying,
hey, we'll throw him under the bus. Let's let this
be true now. So check out MSM news because those
stories existed, but the powers that be made sure
that people never actually saw them. And so we
have to make sure that people have access to this
kind of information. And so whether it's truth,
social media, whether it's MSM news, we are
pushing back and people are finally awake.
Speaker 1: Has no ability to actually take
control of the interview and this MSM news
thing if you check it out it's it says
mainstream news without the mainstream bias
and it's available. I guess it's an app of some
kind that lets you cut through the noise and
it's curated with no and with no censorship. Now,
I don't know how many people understand that, but
it's very hard to say something is curated with no
censorship. I mean, the criticism that they have
of the Facebook and Twitter and etc. algorithms
are it's being curated in a way we don't like.
They will often say if Twitter and Facebook
weren't censored, they would just be chronological
messages from everybody you follow. The algorithm
that curates is a form of censorship, and they're
promoting MSM news as being curated, but without
any censorship. It makes as little sense as it
sounds like it makes. Monday, Memorial Day. We
will be doing our a midterm membership bonanza.
We will be blowing out memberships at a massive
discount. Everybody on my team is saying, David,
sir, please don't do it. Don't do it. It's
too much of a discount. And I am telling them
I'm doing it. On Memorial Day. You'll all be
sleeping and I'll be giving out discounted
memberships. If you want to be notified of this
great discount and you want to sign up on Monday,
Memorial Day, just get on our newsletter at
David Pakman dot com. We'll take a quick break
and be right back. The David Pakman
Show is of course a community supported
program you can sign up at join Pacman dot com
and instantly get access to the world winning I'm
sorry, award winning and world famous bonus show.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and you
can use the coupon code Obamamania for a discount.
Speaker 2: Oh bomb.
Speaker 1: Very important
stuff at join Packman icon.